de tous et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec c'est parfait comme ça
c'est pas familles qui aujourd'hui ont
les sursauts coeurs physiques ce qui est
un jeu de foot extrêmement réaliste
voilà c'est parti ok on y va on connaît
en fait il ya juste une touche mais tout
de suite tenir là de pierre d'hattusha
as tu peux fumer oui tu peux juste sauté
c'est pour ça que tu dis que c'est une
révolution relaté c'est un sale coup
allemand attendu le calme plat donc tu
as gagné
voilà c'était un match très serré au
match non non non non mais attendez faut
prendre les contrôle en main c'est pas
si simple
ce que j'ai fait alors et alors
attention attention à ta job à temps
j'arrive
j'arrive à temps mais quoi tes courses
wallon mr arrête protège le ballon ça
interdit j'en ai pas au rugby c'est
interdit voilà tu lâches le value
puisque mon rugby t'as pas le droit de
aulas rien au lard et oh là là à temps
là je mérite de marquer je mérite regard
c'est bon voilà c'est bon là je vais
marquer j'arrive
j'arrive non aux hommes étaient nazes
5-1 franchement c'était serré quand même
moi j'attends un tennis et d'attendre et
ensuite comme moyen de tourner et bien
passer le ballon comme sérieuses yeux
verts c'est vraiment pas mal incroyable
incroyable mais non et s'ils essayent un
cadeau pour moi balle de match je sais
pas c'est moi j'ai perdu ça m'a troublé
toi attention à temps mais les rebelles
que la taille des bulles quoi attend mal
de matches ok ok pas de match n'ont fait
quoi si tu perds tu fais rien du tout
puisque je vais gagner tu es mort mon
gars prometteuse tu es mort voilà les il
parle ça m'intéresse
jack sanaa mais toi je me dis qu'est ce
qui se passe là avec toi c'était comme
ça alors bitboul c'est parti
alors pas normal c'est parti on perd sur
sur quoi tu ta gueule ton joueur brisé
le cou ton autre joueur quoi donc voilà
c'est une diversion moi j'aime bien
faire des diversions et ensuite je
marque comme ça comme ça comme ça j'ai
beaucoup de bien aux cd c'était beau et
ce petit mouvement comme ça comme ça là
le mouvement
un peu comme ça aulas à l'état tandis
que je souhaite partir et grosses merdes
au regard du soir padeg soient pas des
rig d'aig des attentes autant away la
petitesse qui vibrait aux messages
trouve ça petit à petit c'est ça parle
aucun problème vraiment aller voilà je
t'ai laissé un peu d'avancé aux jolies
l'arrêt au joli joli le nom arrive c'est
pas mal attend la reprise amatrice de
pouce la reprise bien je l'aï reprise
d'un replu dans des cartons les nus on
voit tes tétons boom le petit lob
efficace ma démarche pour le 3 3 ne
trouvent le premier arrivé à cinq matchs
gagnés remporté hockey au nom oui oui et
c'est le annonce a tout gâché à ça
c'était un très beau move au match au
plateau tant qu'acteur c'est l'écart se
creuse de plus en plus la ja ja 3
partout maintenant 4.343 pour moi
quel match on n'a plus de tête
oui je disais que tu as comme ça oui
comme ça ok tu dire comme ça elle est
passée et je n'arrête pas de match c'est
la finale l'an passé la finale comme ça
qu'on fait comme ça pour nom boom
regardait la pédagogie c'est le 7e match
des plus impressionnantes régulation
quel final jean pierre 4 2 non non non
là c'était l'entraînement de la finale
oh oh ouais il a su voir l'ouverture au
bon moment où nos villes et vous attend
cette deuxième enquête
voilà deuxième entraînement là c'est
l'arrêt final ok c'est parti 11 millions
nathan basmaji forme reste par john
qu'est ce qui se passe je fais pareil
hockey balle balle de finale mon gars
ouais bah j'aurais juste aimé finir ma
phrase avant avant que tu gagnes le
match je te prends à west brom
voilà j'ai jamais joué que j'aime pas
que ça ressemble on vient trouver ça
c'est parti moi j'ai un mouton tout que
jon fosse marcher la tête par terre pour
gagner aux points kenny castel a touché
le sol à plat
alela diane et non non vas-y je te
laisse pousser tu as gagné un point très
inquiet ce parti la grande finale
puisque à égalité non non non mais tu
sais au 17 17
la tête elle a touché de brandon plus
tard mais vas-y fais de la compétition
tu m'as tu as eu ce que tu méritais ma
demande pour moi ah ouais c'était
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
margot bonjour il faut que tu fasses un
truc
oui c'est sa prise de judo s était
parfaite à tous petits prix de judo
ouais pourquoi à chaque fois que je
finis avec quelqu'un sur ce genre de
choses je perds et voilà c'est la fin de
cette vidéo gshc vous a plu il m'a
défoncé bravo à mika voilà ni camille
4ème génération de la plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à me les vidéos comme
d'habitude
et puis on se retrouve très vite dans
une nouvelle vidéo tient tout le monde
pis
[Musique]